there are people with incredible talent
and no motivation and then there are
other people that are willing to work
their ass off us above winning a contest
it's about like that one time yeah I got
that this is what I love doing more than
anything and I would do it for free
like any day of the week there were
times when when I started our company
birdhouse in the first three years in we
were ready to give in he's an American
professional skateboarder actor and
owner of the skateboard company
birdhouse he's widely considered to be
one of the pioneers and most successful
influencers of modern vertical
skateboarding throughout his career has
made a number of appearances in films
other media and his own line of video
games he's Tony Hawk and here's my take
on his top 10 rules of attack
rule number three is our personal
favorite and make sure to stick around
all the way to the end to a special
bonus clip also as Tony is talking if he
said something that really resonates
with you please leave in the comments
below and put quotes around it so other
people can be inspired as well enjoy
[Music]
it wasn't until I started my own team
when I realized that there are people
with incredible talent and no motivation
and then there are other people that are
willing to work their ass off who don't
have a natural ability but will become
successful because they're so determined
and and I saw it I mean I saw it
especially in a couple of guys that I
first put on the birdhouse team namely
andrew reynolds matt beach matt beach
was in my eyes the most naturally
talented skateboarder that i've ever
seen everything came easy to him and i
you know when I would request these guys
to go on tour all I ask them is that
they skate for exhibitions whatnot Matt
wooden skate half the time we've flown
me Europe I know any money then you know
in our company but I was flying back to
Europe for competitions he would go to
the cantos and not feel like skating and
I was like how can you do that you know
I was just thinking about not just to me
but to yourself like you have this
incredible talent you just don't care
and then I saw Andrew Reynolds who was
the scrappy little guy taking not very
clean but in terms of the style but
trying some of the hardest stuff taking
the heaviest hit but always skating his
ass off and always trying and he has
become probably the most well respected
street skater today Andrew Reynolds me
he formed Baker Brand Death Wish
skateboards the the community of the the
most hardcore skaters these days called
him the boss because he developed his
style because he worked his ass off and
he is a shining example of hard work
Tommy hob is number one
boys figure over Shaq over Iverson over
MJ I just poked on something I have to
do it I'll either get hurt
taken to the hospital trying it I'm
gonna make it and that was the same for
do 900 for the dance team it was my time
to finally do it or be carted off and
try to no there at some point in
everything how you say this is it
together do it 30 trucks and we felt the
groundswell
I wasn't sure if it was an earthquake or
somebody out there doing something
special that moment was probably burned
in most of our minds forever I knew I
wanted to be in the skate industry I
loved skating too much I want I wanted
to be in it I didn't know if I would
make a living as a professional but I
was going to be I was devoted to
skateboarding so I refinanced my house
and took all the money and started a
skateboard company which seems like the
stupidest thing in the world to do when
skating is dying but it was exactly what
what I wanted to do I wanted to be a
company owner be behind the scenes that
quickly sponsor and started and uh for
about three years struggled very very
hard with my partner and I we had pooled
our money together he was a X pro skater
as well and we just we just did
birdhouse and did whatever we could to
get by and all the team was staying on
my couch
and literally like lon changing diapers
I'm like driving guys to these spots
that they're going to get arrested at
because there's no skate park so they're
going to go ride schoolyards and it was
such a strange existence but um but I
loved it because it was skateboarding
and it's exactly what I wanted to do and
so we really hunkered down you know like
I was I was living on Taco Bell and
peanut barn jelly and Top Ramen mmm
probably three years for sure but I
didn't care because it was like I still
got to do what I love that's the thing
is that people think was a struggle in
psyche well no because you know I loved
it too much I still got to go skate and
time to skate I didn't have to go sit
behind a computer for eight hours and
then hope I get time to skate okay ready
and action three two one
I'm glad you're not do that again
Oh
[Music]
I know there are so many kids out there
that feel the way that I did when I was
a kid just awkward and not excelling at
one thing in particular and not cool and
um skiing was my way out of that and I
hope to if not with skateboarding they
find in something else they do but I
hope that they're not afraid to try
something different you can't listen to
the haters that's my best advice to
anyone if I had listened to the haters I
would have quit a long time ago I would
occur when I was 11 years old like I
used to get bashed by professional
skaters because my style was was dorky
or it was all circus it was you know but
you can't you gotta believe in yourself
as far as I know no one's done anything
like this I mean so people keep asking
me questions like well how do you
approach how you I don't know it's going
to find out the hard way yeah it feels
like the first time I try to live like I
just walked up to you it's like holy
that what am I done but I'm up for the
challenge
[Music]
shut up no idea
she was I
someone's on me away Dana give me a
shake somebody will take you will give
me
Tony's gonna do it I think it's going to
be hanging about hazel that looks like a
half head slightly slit but hey I didn't
in my head though
take any powder
come down
the English rise in the settings there's
anybody he was wrong
oh yeah
Oh
anybody we know
Oh
Oh
because running the Tony Hawk Empire
give you the same satisfaction as the
nine goals at the x-games
you know I love I love the challenge of
the business aspects of it but I but I
love that it's still fun I mean the
stuff that I choose to do is only stuff
they're really impatient 'it about yes i
will enjoy seeing through to be honest
the the high that that i go for that is
always striving me is is when i land
something new when i'm trying to learn a
new trick and i make it for the first
time even if it's something someone else
is already done for me like that push
and that that adrenaline and the the
confidence of thinking i can do this and
it's finally doing it you know seeing it
through the and when i landed that's
that's the buzz that's the high for me
like all else above winning a contest
it's about like that one time you know i
got that yeah and I'm older now and now
when I get that feeling it's it's I
guess further between when I feel it and
so when I do it's way more intense it's
like landing your first kickflip it's
yeah it's what it feels like every time
doesn't look as intimidating was not
sitting on top of building structure the
jump is always scary because you want
all your skin anywhere on your legs they
show you covered you sure it's just not
for fashion well that's do my mega board
make it
[Music]
yeah I want to figure out how I could
remove myself in competition and still
be a pro skater and that had not been
done yet
because if you're not going to compete
the magazines aren't going to cover you
your sponsors are likely to drop you and
the kids who are buying your products
are going to forget about you and there
was no such thing as a video skater back
then that hadn't really come into play
yet there's no YouTube
you know the skate videos were usually
based on the the best guys in the
competition and so I went talk to Stacy
uh who was your boss at the facility she
felt it was my coach and and I actually
had my brother come with me as backup
and he you know he approached stasis
would look Tony was really having a
problem with with the competition's it's
you know it's kind of wrecking him it's
ruining the fun of skating and I told
him that and so he said well you know I
understand maybe you might want to take
a break but don't give it up completely
because you may want to come back he may
be you know you may enjoy it and I don't
know if we're going to be able to
sustain your career if you're not
competing and I did take a break I
stopped competing for a while almost a
year maybe a little less and when I came
back to it I came back with sort of a
fresh perspective that I don't really
care how it lays out I'm going to go and
do my best and I'm going to take chances
that I maybe hadn't taken before and if
that's puts me in last place tonight so
be it but if if it's if I succeed I'm
going to be on this whole other level of
skating mm-hmm and that's what happens I
mean and the contest that I won then
and I won by a long shot
you know because I was doing stuff that
was experimental and stuff that I wasn't
really confident with but but I could
pull it through somehow and if it didn't
happen then I didn't do well at all and
I stopped caring about the end result so
much
[Music]
that one
and
[Music]
yeah what is it miss you Charlie
I did it for whenever an air pocket
you're a measure of items a pioneer the
king by the Honolulu designed so I had
out here that isn't Eva anything to me
I'm like Marie misham miram any logical
machinist once I've created one in trip
and don't want to branch out
indiscernible look cool one chives and
tiny unit I someone who is a ended with
all these people will join through real
thankful something Phase II I reflected
and he going for something year cap
seasick be anticipating something good
you see they can fly i here he goes Judy
across these buddies in the water for
fish to swim and crown rasa that's J for
Shawn GW a few people's ID in their
short assess that one
dirty [ __ ] I got big ass to the canyon
a brand-new move by Tony Hawk
always a crowd-pleaser have no exception
that study hall yeah the blistering
place he had to clear to talk he 25-mile
water perform at this behind again due
to these way across the arena off that
run hit it at the diagonal
[Applause]
[Music]
wonderful stuff what a man you're
convinced that you're going to fail our
fall or get hurt that will come to
fruition because that's what you're
visualizing I never vision you know I
was willing to get hurt along the way
but I didn't visualize myself getting
hurt along the way
and I think that's what that's what
stops a lot of people and that's really
what separates a lot of people from
being world champions are from being as
good as they can because they stop at
some point sitting on oh I am not
capable of this or I'll probably get
hurt doing this and if you approach
anything with that hesitation you're
going to fail I always approached it
like this is going to work I'm going to
figure this out even if it takes me
hundreds of attempts and I wasn't you
know the idea of falling getting back up
again that didn't really bother me at
all
[Music]
[Music]
the Pacific
[Music]
[Music]
and I don't really need the money like I
don't need the money anymore
I made dream money from from video games
like stuff that I did things that would
never imagine you know when people say
like is this what you dreamt I didn't
dream any of this none of this was
possible or even considered a reality
when I was a kid you know when I started
skating like the best you could hope for
was your picture in a magazine maybe a
pro board maybe and free gear that's it
and then once you reach the age of
responsibility and this is I'm talking
about when I was like 12 once you reach
an age of responsibility say 18 your
career is over
because you're not you can't make money
doing it you can't do it into your belt
life obviously I'm here thankful to
still be able to just for living like
this is this is what I love doing more
than anything and I would do it for free
like any day of the week you know at any
given time I'd happily just go skate it
just happens to be the thing that I'm
successful at so I get to do what I love
for living and that that's living a
dream I mean in it living a dream I
don't I'm not talking about financial
success I'm talking about loving what
you do you know if you love art you do
art and maybe you get a little bit of
success at it you're living the dream
[Music]
and maybe
there were times when when I started our
company birdhouse in the first three
years in we were ready to give in you
know with the sales just wasn't weren't
there the interest wasn't there and same
with my skating like I was I was still
improving my skills but for no audience
so it was definitely difficult but but
we embrace those challenges too
especially as athletes
I mean you someone someone poses a
challenge to you and you have to figure
out how to get over it and so in in
doing that in my skating and also in the
business it was like well these are
what's what's coming at us we've got to
figure out how to navigate this and how
to succeed and a lot of people just give
up
oh no and and especially in skating I
mean that's the first sign of someone
that's going to successful no matter how
far no matter how successful they get
especially in competition they continue
to challenge themselves because they
want to improve those are the guys that
make it way further the name
ah Your Honor I'm here on behalf of the
great state of Alabama to prove once and
for all that skateboarding is was and
always has been a crime and that this
man Anthony Francis Haywood
Buford Hall should be found guilty of
perpetrating the most gnarly of offenses
mr. hawk would you like to make an
opening remark yeah I guess but I think
skip earning is not a crime talk there
is no halfpipe they can launch you out
of hell and what was mr. Hawk doing at
the time he's rivaling those planks with
wheels objection skateboarding is
allowed in public areas well I just
thought that doesn't seem like something
you should do mr. hawk how long have you
been riding these devil mobiles
pretty much my whole life let the record
show that mr. Hawk was carving a
pentagram into his chest as he answered
no I wasn't let me ask you something boy
I'm in my mid-40s if God had intended us
to skateboard
why wouldn't he have blessed us with
wheels instead of feet I don't know why
did he give us legs instead of trucks or
why did he not put little decals of
skulls on our bellies I put a heap of
tape on all back I get it the Bible says
Lo and man shall not step on a wheeled
plank revelation 20:13 now I personally
can't think of anything more simple than
somebody launching off of vert ramp into
a kickflip McTwist but for those who
need convincing maybe you can enlighten
us professor I've discovered several
eyewitness accounts of skateboarding at
some of history's greatest crimes this
is a picture of Tony Hawk high-fiving
Adolf Hitler that's obviously doctored
this is Tony doing what appears to be a
nollie off the balcony moments after
Lincoln was shot this is insane and this
is Tony grinding down the tail of a
dinosaur moments before the meteor hit
exterminated all dinosaur life on the
planet Earth on Owen's country I
invented the railing to provide a stable
grabbing surface for god-fearing
stair-climbing men and women not to be
grinded on by some amoral beast trying
to pull up a frontside boardslide
nothing human uses a railing like that
you have displaced my work sir you have
disgraced the work of Phineas kill
railing now I rest my case
I find you dizzy mr. Hawke and declare
skate boat in a crime
you can't would you like to say anything
before I pass sentence nothing else you
can do I hereby sentence you to change
to respectable mode of transportation
right near the skillet all right today
is June 27th 2016 and it is 17 years to
the date that I landed my first 900 at
the X Games in San Francisco a lot has
happened since then in my life I mean
it's been the craziest roller-coaster
ride and it really was the apex of my
competitive career so I'm going to try
900 today because I feel like I can and
I never thought be doing this at my age
when I was you know I really didn't
think that was a possibility but I'm
still going and going to the wheels fall
off I guess
[Applause]
since we was there when my first one
no he was on my left by
thank you guys so much for watching I
made this video because venom Leon
athlete ooh so there's a famous
entrepreneur that you want me to profile
next leave it down the comments below
and I'll see what I could do I also love
to know what did Tony say that has the
biggest impact on you what lesson did
you learn that you're going to
immediately apply to your life or to
your business leave in the comments that
I'm going to join in the discussion
finally I want to give a quick shirt at
the Q Gobert Hugo's thank you so much
for picking up a cup of my book your one
word and taking that awesome picture and
post it on Twitter I'm really curious to
understand what you were looking at in
that picture I love a bro and really
appreciate the support so thank you guys
again for watching I believe in you I
hope you continue to believe in yourself
and whatever your one word is much loved
I'll see you soon
the moment when I knew I wanted to skate
and not do other sports was the first
time I went to a skate park and saw
people flying out of pools all my life I
was trying to find a buzz and I didn't
really get it from team sports I was
okay at baseball in basketball but I
didn't I wasn't improving at a rate I
could see and then when I went to the
skate park for the first time I
literally saw these guys going into a
pool and flying I was like that's it and
then I started trying to figure out how
to do that I did it in the little pools
I saw a picture of Steve Caballero who
was about my size but just a little bit
older and he was doing an air and
Winchester like three or four feet out I
saw these guys they were older and more
experienced doing these things and it
looked intimidating but it looked
awesome when I saw Steve Caballero he
was my size near my age and he was
literally flying and I was like he can
do it I can do that
I know I may not do it as well as him or
as much as much style but I'm gonna
learn how to do that and that was the
moment that was the moment when I
decided I was going to do that because I
did like that it was made me different
and it was something that identify stuff
myself with and I it's made me stand
apart from everyone else and went to
school with all the most other kids my
age you know I I did appreciate that but
at the same time I always wondered why
don't they like this you know this is
this is amazing like this is it's super
difficult it's adrenaline filled it's
dangerous there's a sense of
accomplishment you know what are they
missing about this and it was always
just never really hit in those days and
so yeah I guess I would be the one to
either blame or credit for doing
mainstream stuff and hopefully making it
acceptable or making it authentic you
ever scared out there I mean some of
this stuff is just insane ever kind of
like at the top of something we're about
to do I believe oh geez oh I could break
my neck here uh yeah for sure but but
that is you know that's that's the best
gauge of should you be doing it or not
it's more about for me it's about
approaching things with confidence if
I'm going to
do something I've already convinced
myself that I can do it that it is
possible if I go at it and I think I
don't know if this is going to work
definitely I get hurt let's regular you
know I mean if you can't just throw
caution to the wind and go out let's see
what happens yeah and you know
especially at my age and and having this
much experience and having so many
injuries along the way I'm Way more
methodical about learning things you
know I mean it takes me way more tries
and and I have to know that it's going
to work before I go out and try to make
it as a new dad who loves sports and
wants one day to inspire my new son I'm
wondering what advice you have that
either your dad Frank gave you or that
you have given your kid to do what you
love doing
you know don't don't succumb to peer
pressure or adult pressure find your
voice find find what you really enjoy
and even if it's something different and
it's something that's not considered
cool if you love doing it
you will thrive in it and and eventually
you'll be happy because you continue to
do it if that would Frank what am i dad
you know I was I was the youngest of
four and by the time I came around he
had seen it all
and so we just like go just do it
whatever it is you know and I chose to
do the most sort of offbeat thing that
all the of my siblings but he was really
supportive and and I was lucky in that
and and I that's the same kind of
approach I have to my kids you know if
they love doing it I don't care if it's
not considered the cool thing or you
know or if it doesn't mean that they're
going to get a varsity letter I want
them to be happy and I want them to
enjoy themselves